sophie brochu présidente directrice
générale d'hydro-québec bonsoir en
france il alors les tarifs réglementés
question règle en parler de la question
des tarifs d'abord il y avait il n'y a
pas si longtemps de régie de l'énergie
et vous deviez hydro québec allait
plaider dire on a besoin de 2 % de 3%
parce qu'on a t'elle poteau à acheter
telle chose à acheter c'est selon vos
besoins l'eau est ce que vous les pôles
l on a laissé la bride que le cheval va
galoper ça va nous coûter cher peu
importe vos besoins réels
non d'abord le cheval qui galope pour
rien là je veux bien construit en
préambule à la direction d'hydro-québec
et toute l'organisation leur fait tout
ce qu'elle peut pour gérer ses coûts au
mieux le rendez vous avec la régie dans
le cas de la loi 34 il ya un rendez vous
avec la régie aux cinq ans le prochain
en 2020
2025 la régie vous regardez l'ensemble
des coûts encourus par hydro québec
regardez sa structure de coûts
d'exploitation ces investissements les
voies juger si ces couleurs qui ont été
encourus justement sont justes et
raisonnables qui ont été fait un bon pas
vos bonnes mères de famille alors n'y
voyais à pied si jamais la régie dit
c'est cool je ne les offre 3 ports je ne
les reconnaît pas y voyant une réduction
tarifaire doute donc il faut d'abord
faut se faire un peu je sais que c'est
grave ce que je veux faire un peu
confiance présentement là on est dans
une situation où il ya une pression
inflationniste sur les coûts on la vit
chez hydro-québec on la gère au mieux on
revient de l'ensemble des coûts d'un
bébé des projets d'investissement condor
on cherche les moyens de réduire la
pression sur nos coûts d'alimentation de
la régie va avoir l'occasion de regarder
ça mais ya pas de cheval qui court avec
la bride sur le cou on n'est pas du tout
dans cette mais on a des coûts
importants il faudra les assumer alors
l'idée la danse et d assumer ok donc 2,6
dans quelques jours 1er avril et 3 pour
ça c'est plafonné à 3 % au 1er avril
2003 l'esprit l'inflation tout indique
qu'elle va se maintenir mais si jamais
vous n'avez pas besoin de toi pour ça
c'est possible
ça veut dire que le gouvernement vous
avez donné plus de redevances au
gouvernement
avec moi ce que vous dites c'est vrai et
vous savez quoi dans d'autres
juridictions l'actionnaire c'est pas du
gouvernement c'est un propriétaire privé
qui rémunère des actionnaires côté
hambourg fait que tu es en train de dire
que sur scène nous donne l'occasion de
surcharger vous dire qu'on ne recherche
pas je peux juste vous nommez exemple
exactement tout ce qu'on fait en cyber
sécurité présente mal et on engage et
dizaines et des dizaines et des dizaines
de personnes qui méritent des pressions
sur les coûts on a débuté un contrôle de
végétation plus accéléré pour éviter les
pannes la cia port il ya pas de dahmane
qui fuit le québec si la puis l'idée
hydro-québec ses potes de maximiser le
profit du gouvernement sur ses pots
majeur ma job avec l'équipe de direction
avec tous hydro québec c'est de dire on
a un service à rendre il faut qu'ils
soient fiables soient pérennes d'antan
ou pire qu'en fin de la transition
énergétique pour qu'on fasse on au
meilleur coût possible ça c'est une
posture mais bon puis c'est encore une
fois si comme vous dites si le 3 pour ça
ne correspond pas à vos besoins meilleur
opus d'argent au gouvernement et non pas
actionnaire privé comme c'est bon les
besoins oui la demande explose vous le
dites dans votre plan
mail térawattheures d'ici 2050 de plus
pourquoi on projette pas tout de suite
de bâtir un autre barrage par exemple
aucune annoncé 100 térawattheures soit
pas besoin d'une crise de câbles
s'agirait alors pourquoi fais pas ça
parce que d'abord on va dès 4 ans quand
on décide de mettre en oeuvre de
nouveaux ouvrages il faut qu'on ait une
une certitude quant aux besoins et quant
au moment précis où plus ou moins précis
de ce besoin la carte on regarde devant
nous on a oui on a une demande qui
s'accroît parce que en une transition
énergétique cette transition énergétique
en sorte qu'on veut qu'elle ait
davantage de consommation qui
aujourd'hui sont servis par des énergies
fossiles pour qu'ils viennent sur le
système électrique mais ça crée des
besoins alors qu'est ce qu'on fait remy
la première chose qu'il faut qu'on fasse
monsieur voix c'est de l'efficacité
énergétique puis des gens il ya
quelqu'un qui se devait prophète
d'efficacité énergétique la consommation
plus responsable pour l'électricité une
énergie qui est proche les gens voyaient
pas l'intérêt y en a d'autres qui disent
eh ben moi si j'ai un incitatif 200
pièces par année ça change pas ma vie
fait j'ai pas besoin de casser la tête
avec ça et aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire
parce que ça va nous permettre
d'accueillir des volumes supplémentaires
sur notre réseau des rires des gens
-cinq obligé de faire tout de suite les
investissements et nous permet de
reporter l'investissement l'exemple que
je donne c'est comme si depuis des
décennies au québec on roule dans le but
de l'électricité puis il y avait plus de
vent que deux passagers y a plus de
capacités que le besoin qui offert d
élire des gens qui sont entrés dans le
top mais il ya encore de la place fait
qu'on met novembre sur des bas et on met
des valises sur des mâts il ya des gens
qui veulent en crue dans le besoin
d'électricité qu'est ce qu'on fait on
laisse nos manteaux son rival et on
achète un autobus ou bien d'iomega
ouvertement si on va laisser rentrer le
plus de gens possible dans le but
vainqueur ce soir qu' on construira et
donc c'est son efficacité et c'est très
important c'est quand j'entendais que je
comprends que il ya des gens qui
voudraient qu'on fasse plus d'efficacité
mais en même temps tu qu'on fait est
énorme c'est l'équivalent de la romaine
puisqu'on fait chez nous monsieur roy
puis c'est pour moi l'os hydro québec
c'est le creuset de toutes les
intentions de la société
les gens voudraient qu'on fasse beaucoup
d'efficacité qu'on construit en eux
qu'ils voudraient qu'on construise des
barrages il y en a qui veulent pas qu'on
construise des barrages il y en a qui
veulent qu'on réduise les gaz et nam ou
quelques réalités
je comprends mais l'efficacité
énergétique vous vous visez quoi le 8 là
je peux me tromper d'embaucher plus de
huit mois de ça c'est quoi vous êtes
l'équivalent de la romaine
il faut qu est ce que ça suppose pour
que les gens réapprennent à vivre avec
l'électricité il faut qu'on vous le
redonne faux comment on faire un peu de
ce qu'on va faire c'est que d'abord on
va partager avec les citoyens avec nos
clients davantage d'outils pour leur
donner des incitatifs à des places
commençons par ça à déplacer dans le
temps les jours où il fait très froid
les consommations comme les sécheuses
les lave vaisselle ce qu'ils consomment
beaucoup d'électricité
aujourd'hui l'électricité mais se voit
quand on se compare avec le reste du
monde si le tarif et les cris
présidentielle le moins cher en amérique
fait on n'est pas les meilleurs auront
en termes de consommation d'électricité
est ce qu'on veut c'est donner des
incitatifs aux gens posés si vous
diminuez votre consommation ou si vous
la déplacer dans le temps on va vous
donner des incitatifs financiers puis ça
ça nous évite de faire des
investissements de centaines et de
centaines et de centaines de millions de
dollars pour servir une fois de
quelques-uns oui et tout le monde est
d'accord pour qu'on soit plus efficace
puisqu'elle ça c'est sûr mais en même
temps vous le dites vous-même ça sera
pas suffisant il vendra loire à terme
construire donc il ya des projets de
barrages de d'abord y en at il sont-ils
localiser et 15 hockey elle attend des
choses qu'on fait en fait de
l'efficacité en parallèle on n'allait
pas aller au modernisme central existant
ans et robert bourassa pensée m'a
dépassé toutes les centrales hydro
québec il y avait 40 à 30 ans un quart
dans 20 ans on les modernise quand on
met de nouveaux gros quand on met de
nouveaux équipements ils sont plus
efficaces ça va nous donner de 1000
mégawatts
l'autre affaire qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va constituer un portefeuille de
projets éoliens on va faire ça avec les
acteurs du milieu on va encore sur 3000
mégawatts dire on sait qu'on peut
développer tel projet éolien de par
exemple 250 mégawatts dans telle région
à tel ou tel moment est offert résulte
l'allemand va but et on va déclencher
ces projets éoliens là pour servir la
demande qui ça au fil du temps on va
voir l'évolution de la transition
énergétique
est-ce que ça va aller plus vite - v
est-ce que ça va être de la même ampleur
de plus grande ampleur dans moins
d'emplois et au final on va se projeter
dans le temps comme ça de 10 15 ans à 10
15 ans pour s'assurer que si on doit
déclarer déclencher un barrage je compte
pas besoin de faire à court ou moyen
terme et si on doit faire ça c'est parce
que ce sera nécessaire déclencher un
barrage des enjeux environnementaux
s'il ya des enjeux comme donne et
puissants jets de koubia voir faire ça
on peut faire mieux collectivement pour
approvisionner le québec pour remplir le
tourbus cocon l'heure j'ai compris
l'image mais veulent le deuxième autobus
là où une autre centrale quand même dans
10 ans parce qu'il faut prévoir soit
bien avant évidemment vous le savez
mieux points ça sera pas c'est pas
inévitable c'est en fait en fait vous me
dire est-ce que c'est inévitable je vous
donne je vous donne un autre exemple
d'abord je n'ai pas une question là
hydro québec depuis toujours on le fait
encore et on le fera toujours on tient à
jour une liste de projets on étudie le
rôle ici on regarde quels sont les
impacts des changements climatiques sur
les niveaux d'eau sur les feux de forêt
dans les régions dont on regarde tous ok
puis cela c'est notre responsabilité
c'est de s'assurer que on a la pleine
vue sur ce qui peut se faire en termes
de potentiel hydroélectrique mais on
n'est pas des castors on n'est pas des
casseurs qui voulons construire à tout
prix alors je vous donne un autre
exemple ce qui fait aujourd'hui qu'on
met tous ces moyens là en neuf c'est
parce que la demande augmente finalement
moment chez nous puis au sud de la
frontière puis pour sur un horizon de 15
20 et 1 on a des capacités qu'on peut
valoriser sur le marché américain on en
a déjà parlé d'eux et moi l'attrait et
un écho j'ai là vont arriver à échéance
avec les capacités condé dit ce
religieux au sud de notre frontière
c'est une partie de ce qu'on va pouvoir
repli chez nous au moment où nous en
avons besoin je compte donc on va donc
voir se reparler mais avant de vous
laisser parce que l'auteur fait les
bornes pour les voitures électriques est
ce qui va avoir un réseau plus robuste
et cas oui il va y avoir un réseau que
vos bus c'est hydro québec ont investi
dans les réseaux
du circuit électrique puisqu'il faut il
faut pas qu'ils draw québec respire tout
merde il ya un secteur privé qui est en
train de développer qui on va le
développer avec eux puis on voit
investir en bourse dont le mit dans le
plan de nombreuses à l'eau et moi je dis
qu'avec les chiffres demandés mais paul
chez votre mail térawattheures en tout
par exemple manceau nul mais blague à
part louis brison qui va être plus
robuste puis c'est pas juste hydro
québec qui va faire sur cette secteur
privé aussi se fait brochure toujours un
plaisir vous répondez aux questions
merci de nous avoir parlé on va suivre
ça merci beaucoup c'est baisse du mois
saluent bien bon soit au riz